موجز الاخبار اهلا بكم قالت وزاره الصحه
الفلسطينيه ان شابا فلسطينيا استشهد
متاثرا بجروح اصيب بها برصاص الاحتلال في
قريه زعتره جنوبي نابلس وكان الهلال
الاحمر الفلسطيني قد اعلن اصابه نحو 100
فلسطيني نتيجه اعتداءات المستوطنين في
حواره وكان العشرات من المستوطنين قد
اضربوا النار في عدد من السيارات ومنازل
ومحال تجاريه في حوار احتجاجا على مقتل
المستوطنين اثنين في حادث اطلاق نار في
القريه
خرجت مسيرات في عدد من المدن والبلدات في
الضفه الغربيه ضد الاعتداءات الاسرائيليه
ففي نابلس هدف المتظاهرون ضد الاجراءات
والاعتداءات الاسرائيليه كما خرجت مظاهره
حاشده في رام الله تطالب بحمايه
الفلسطينيين من الاعتداءات الاسرائيليه في
بلده حواره وفي جميع المدن والبلدات
الفلسطينيه هذا وقال الناطق باسم قوات
الاحتلال ان الجيش دفع بكتيبتين عسكريتين
جديدتين الى الضفه الغربيه كما اعلنت قوات
الاحتلال تشديد الاجراءات الامنيه في محيط
نابلس
قال رئيس الحكومه الاسرائيليه بنيامينه
ياهو ان البناء الاستيطانيه وتشريع البؤر
الاستيطانيه في الضفه الغربيه سيتواصلان
دون اي تغيير جاء كلام نتنياهو في اول رد
فعل حكومي على نتائج اجتماع العقبه واورد
البيان المشترك للاجتماع ان الجانبين
الفلسطيني والاسرائيلي اكد التزامهما بخفض
التصعيد ومنع المزيد من العنف ووفق البيان
فان الطرفين اعلن التزامهما بوقف
الاجراءات الاحاديه من ثلاثه اشهر الى سته
كما قال البيان ان اسرائيل التزمت بوقف
مناقشه انشاء اي وحدات استيطانيه جديده
لمده اربعه اشهر
وقال وزير الخارجيه الامريكيين اجتماع
العقبه خطوه ايجابيه للاسرائيليين
والفلسطينيين ومن الاهميه متابعه الطرفين
لخطوات تهدئه التوترات واستعاده الهدوء
وكانت الفصائل الفلسطينيه في غزه قالت ان
المشاركه الفلسطينيه في اجتماع العقبه
جريمه وطنيه لا يمكن السكوت عنها وكانت
الفصائل الفلسطينيه بالقطاع قد عقدت
اجتماعا طارئا لبحث موقفها من اجتماع
العقبه ومشاركه السلطه الفلسطينيه فيه
وحذر المجتمعون من مخرجات اجتماع العقبه
قال الرئيس الروسي ان روسيا في مواجهه
فعليه مع النيتو وان على بلاده ان تاخذ
بعين الاعتبار القدرات النوويه لدول
الناتو كبريطانيا وفرنسا في الاثناء قالت
قياده الاركان الاوكرانيه ان قواتها صدت
واحدا وسبعين هجوما معظمها في محاور
القتال في اقليم دومباس واضافت انها احبطت
العديد من المحاولات الروسيه للتقدم نحو
مواقع قواتها في مدينه
العسكريه للعاصمه الاوكرانيه ان العاصمه
تتعرض لهجوم الجوي بطائرات مسيره متفجره
من جهه اقلت قياده عمليات شمالي اوكرانيا
انه تم اسقاط ثلاث مسيرات في سماء العاصمه
كيف
ختام الموجز الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]